when the uh jackass pilot was coming
together I had an offer to be in a music
video for the band Offspring and they
were like you can't do this and that and
I was like H I think I'm going to go
with the Spike Jones
project well you couldn't do an
offspring video and jackass whoever I
was talking to was a little bit
bullheaded about it and ever since then
whenever Offspring has come on the radio
I'm like turn it off I can't is that why
yeah because it reminds you that
situation yeah I don't even remember who
I was talking to but I didn't like the
way that they spoke to me oh my go every
time it comes on you're like turn that F
off but it's because it reminds you of
just a resentment it's just all of it
it's all of it oh my God that would all
make sense